oh good morning it's gaming week gamers
and
grab your pickaxe because it's minecraft
time isn't that right sven
sven agrees excellent
we made a lot of changes to the not
really
i just got uh these items on the wall
so like now i know what's in each thing
it's pretty epic thank you guys for
giving the tips also i'm freaking rich
now
isn't that right sven we are super rich
yes we are
you're not getting anything all right
there's one thing i wanted to do
uh yes yes wait it's coming sven don't
worry
uh you guys told me you can dye his
collar if you just add a die on it and
click
on it so like oh my god
sven you look amazing seriously
so good here you go love you uh what
else
what else we got llama and
mook and water cow water sheep is still
here of course
water sheep you wouldn't think about
escaping would you wow you look so sexy
lisa that's what i thought
you never speak until i spoken to be
quiet garbage
you're trash your sub human trash yeah
i've been making sure to feed him so he
doesn't despawn
uh just enough to keep him alive
there you go don't
give me hearts uh what else jurgens here
cow is here
llama here very epic time oh yes you
guys told me
you can just place a carpet you don't
have to have a gate you can just put a
carpet
nice nice job notch you dummy thick uh
we also have
pigs now i guess i don't know this is
pretty boring there you go there you go
also chickens hello chickens sorry i
forgot your food
oh no you're gonna starve oh this is so
sad oh yeah and you guys told me how to
fix the farming with the pumpkins and
the
cactuses because uh you have to place a
block spare one so now
this is good business is good i'm not
gonna lie this minecraft veteran knows
what he's doing
oh yeah i remember i want to burn down
this tree because it's in the way and
it's super annoying hello
there you go burn
epic burn time oh yes i wanted to do
this as well
uh so you guys told me you guys told me
sven what are you doing there
you guys oh god i shouldn't be walking
around with this in my hand
sven come in please i need to make a
banner oh perfect i have sex
okay um it says your mother is a taste
sexy ladies okay
[Music]
and then bing bong bing bong listen i
remember
because i minecraft before you
be quiet what oh it worked okay cool uh
yellow dye yellow dye yellow dye
where is my yellow dye hello how are you
that's not going to be enough where is
it hi how are you
is this going to be enough bing bong uh
ah
what happened are you okay
eat potato say i bro oh there you go
okay okay gosh be careful it's a co i
put a carpet here
just sit sit sit
good boy okay and then we make swedish
banner and then apparently
i can do this
oh oh yeah gamers
oh yeah it's gaming week god damn we
look good can i see it
yeah me and the boys me and the boys
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah hey sven
please look at this look at this dude
that's awesome thanks for all the tips
guys now we do have some plans for today
and uh it's gonna be pretty epic because
if you remember
last episode we had a little problem
with some raiders
they're gonna die basically
how do i make dynamite okay i think i
remember
a bing bong bing bong bong
and bing bong okay cool
sven i would bring you with me but it's
gonna be pretty dangerous
all right it's gaming week let's
freaking get it
should i make gucci pants everyone keep
saying i should make gucci pants
all right let's make gucci pants i've
been wanting to make gucci pants for a
very long time what's a green dye kelp
maybe yo no hello kelp is kelp a green
dye let's check it out
no it isn't i need the green gucci pants
i can't go on an
adventure without gucci pants how to
make gree
gucci pants green dye cactus
oh i have those bing bong bing bing bing
bong
let's get that melon die wait what you
never played super similar
you cook the cactus so this is how gucci
does it huh
whoa you can cook cactus blast
protection fire protection
okay so how do you make leather armor
boom okay gamers okay okay okay gamers
bing bang bong my
fat schlong here we go why do i make it
green
blue would be so much cooler what am i
doing
i mean it is gucci though okay fine okay
fine i'll change them
i'll change i'll change i'll change it
okay okay
all right me and the boy
ready for some adventure a red
horror all right we'll see how this goes
hold down the fort for me sven oh there
it is
we're gonna blow it up gonna blow it to
smithereens
baby with this fish that's right okay
so maybe if i ru okay the plan is i rush
in
i block out all the exits i set up the
bomb
and then i blow it up in front of them
so i can see their tears
while i do it look at them look at the
idiots
that they're talking about dumb stuff
okay here we go
get out of my way gamers boom don't
think so
okay so we want one on each floor right
ah what slight problem in the matrix you
can't put redstone downwards what is
this gamer weak
are you kidding me yeah yeah it works
look gamers it works
okay
we just gotta get rid of the stairs look
how angry
nothing's going to save you nothing
there's another bomb here then i don't
know how it works
i'm out of redstone
it's going to be a short fuse boys it's
going to be a
it's going to be a short piece okay
okay all right gamers
it's gaming week
what happened nothing happened
no i'm dying defense defense
oh god i thought i blew it up we've been
set up it was a trap
jesus christ that's a lot of them it's
all right it's gaming week
ah frick it okay oh my god there's
so many she believe a swedish
meatball she says okay okay okay
new plan new plan new plan new plane
oh god i'm scared that's so many
okay
here we go here we go
they didn't explode
[Applause]
here we go
gamer got wrecked
give me all your stuff oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa look they dropped cactus
gamers time to bounce hoes mad hoes man
okay i think that was pretty successful
oh man again it was amazing
i wish you could be there so much
okay we're gonna stock up on hey and
meet because
we are gonna head out i really wanna go
on an adventure with jurgen and sven
together
and you guys told me that you can put
sven
and jurgen with you on a boat so i'm
like okay well that's epic
so sven pack up your best
smile because today we ride together
let's see is there a direction i haven't
had it yet like i headed south
maybe we should try this directions swan
you're coming with us right
he's so cute what are we gonna find who
knows
epic gaming adventure water awesome
so i think i have to put the leash on
jurgen
okay sven in the boat in the boat you go
go in the boats then it's safe don't
worry there you oh
so cute yeah i got it come back
gosh damn it okay and now i go inside is
he still in
oh yes oh my god does it work
oh my god yes
oh heck yeah me and the boys
on adventure so i think i've been there
maybe i should just head south you okay
you're again let me know if you want
break
swedish viking discovers new lands
oh man i want to find out underwater
temple that'd be so cool
i know they are in the game but i never
found one yet
yeah again uh jurgen
no no no you're again you're you're
again you're again
what are you doing the lasso oh god
jargon please i thought you were safe
my god at least sven stays in the boat
can we get a life jacket for sven please
we found those
sunken ship gamers with magma blocks
we found a sunken temple okay this is
perfect then
stay in the boat do his practice jurgen
stay in the sand first we discover the
water
oh my god uh whoa it could be dangerous
inside
well i never gotten these materials
before could this be a water temple
man i'd be so happy
[Music]
this is a ruin isn't it no treasure if i
can get epic gamer loot then don't waste
my time isn't that right year again
there we go let's see this is what i'm
talking okay
all right it's good for jurgen maybe not
for me anything else there's usually two
all right gaming must go on
loot or without luke it's not about what
we find it's about having fun guys don't
worry
we'll find the gamer lou oh epic
oh heck yeah all right jurgen you can
come with me
man stay in the boat guard the boats man
so this is how i got so rich because
these you can get
a ton of hay from or wheat or whatever i
just stole
i just stole everyone's wheat and sold
it to them and they paid me a bunch of
money
stoinks everyone hi gamers
just want your stuff you see we grabbed
these and we resell them just give me
one moment
hello sarah want to do business
okay epic
pleasure doing business with you god
damn these guys are rich
unlike these poor cities i keep going to
oh look the stoner is having a bat
that's cute
are you enjoying okay never mind then
it's getting dark maybe i should sleep
here
what up gamers did you sleep well you're
so cute
all right we head out jorgen is a little
scared of water
but it's safe don't worry we're looking
for water temple we will find
water temple oh found one
is the organ going to be okay if i leave
him in the water what happens to jorgen
does he go down with me let's swim here
again
oh god it's dangerous here again back
off back off buckle
oh whoa whoa whoa
get him sven
whoa he dropped gold heck yeah i'm just
here for the loot gamer oh there
there is none you're getting my god
you're scaring sven you're again
come back even in the water
that's literally physically impossible
what you just did
come here we're not leaving jurgen we're
not leaving
it's better if you got you know what
jurgen one would never do this
jesus christ hey look another city we
can do stoics in
all right gamers wait by the boat jesus
christ the rich
now now i can afford buying gucci pants
instead of making them
instead of making fake ones this is
amazing
jesus christ there's many
is this is there a pirate ship in your
city
what this
is even oh my god that's crazy
bonus meme there's a cat oh my god yes
i've been carrying out fishes just so i
can tame you
hey kitty you're going in the bucket
all right so you got to sneak up to the
kitties hey kitty kitty kitty kitty
hey
[Music]
maybe we need to paralyze it first hey
kitty kitty get in here
where did he go
[Music]
you didn't see anything there can't be
no witnesses
so it's dark now but i think that might
actually be better because
now we can see uh the water
if it lifts up
whoa look at that dude
whoa whoa whoa okay it's a harpoon guy
oh god i can't deal with harpoon guy
oh god all right it's gaming time oh god
you're good
be brave be brave you're good
jesus
oh it actually hit me damn it
where is he come up coward
oh god he hit you again i'm done
i'm done diggin
x-men he is
yeah this is not okay
okay all right gamers
first first year again
there you go second jargon
i'm probably the only one dumb enough to
do this okay his health is full
okay another water temple this one
doesn't look so bad
okay you're getting what are you doing
get up there
no no no no no no jurgen jurgen swim up
swim up
swim up swim up
no i can't do this i can't do it with it
swim up
you made it again
eat my gamer dude all right we're going
home we're going home
no treasure is valuable more than jurgen
and you sven you're not a submarine
jurgen i don't know what gave you the
idea
whoa what's happening what's happening
sven sven
swami's right oh god
[Music]
come back
where is he
no god dammit
stay there sven
sven sven
he must be here sven he wouldn't just
disappear
he can breathe in the water yo again
i can't find him sven
ah maybe he got lost
where are you where are you
[Music]
y'all can stop swaying away you heard
him right i'm not crazy right
go down
[Music]
sven
where are you fed what if i build a
plateau
maybe he will teleport
no why do i hear him
i hear him still he's out there
how do i get him back
it's not over jargon
where is he i don't care how much these
are worth i'll save you again for any
price
can you teleport here teleport your
again
teleport
[Music]
oh
oh we're gonna get you out of here buddy
we're gonna get you it's not a good
place to be
it's not a
okay deep breath
hey breath oh god all right i might have
to
build like a tunnel oh
god don't know how to do this you must
be so scared you're
again you must have been so scared as
long as we don't run out of the air
so he could just swim here no but the
bubbles might grab him
right so let's set up a defense that
will not take me or jurgen
or sven can he swim what if i put the
leash on him
oh god no no no no more
oh god okay okay okay
okay let's cover up this hole
oh god he's struggling he's struggling
it's okay don't worry don't worry
okay okay i got an idea i got an idea
yeah again
i found him i found him jargon he's safe
you're gonna at least pretend that
you're happy
okay we're gonna have to grab you don't
care you're
you don't like water here again we have
to
ride like the wind jurgen
ride like the goddamn wind
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on
stay with llama oh god i used up all my
materials
sven is all alone in a cave water
come on come on goodbye swan was like
the father i never had
it was like a child to me
he was like my own son okay gamers
i need your help
any tip i can get to get sent out of
this cave
i will take gladly
help a gamer out don't worry to save
they're gonna the nine-year-olds
the nine-year-olds are gonna save us oh
my god oh it hurts to stop here
you